okay for people joining this live stream
we are doing a design review of some new
functionality
uh coming after version 12.3 and
somebody has a bunch of background noise
here and should
uh view themselves um the
this is about the system services
functionality and i don't
see uh
why is bradley not here
why is brad not here i thought he was
the person
well the the main part of
this design review is to talk about the
wolfram language api that we're
designing for this
not not so much the the list of services
but rather
that should be here can somebody find
him please okay
um okay
so let's understand
the um why isn't this working
okay the basic story here
okay so what is system service it's a
rapper of some kind
is that right constantine is
service there's a set of functionality
for seeing the list of all supported
system services getting values uh you
know configured values for those
services
and setting configured values for those
services this is basically a way
it's an api for wrapping up a unified
api
for setting and getting various
configuration values related to
mostly kind of outside services so that
users can
swap in and out uh different values for
those
you know for the configuration settings
for those services
is this a special case of persistent
value
or how persistent are these things
supposed to be
they're they're persistent it's
implemented with persistent value
but so how global is the persistent
value
that is if i set something for a
geoserver for example
i might very well want that to go across
cloud and multiple machines and all this
kind of thing
but if i set something for my local
object store
i don't want that to go across multiple
machines
yeah so you can use that the same way as
persistent values so you can store it in
the cloud
or in the local machine so it supports
all those locations
okay how do i specify that additionally
you can
you can just have a directory with that
uh no no no no no no i'm not done
there's a location section
uh there's a lot of sexual development
okay so
so another question where is the list of
services
to which um that this is supposed to
apply to
also the very bottom okay so here's
location
and these are some of the services that
this applies to
this list which goes on quite a bit
below is not necessarily a completely
comprehensive list it's
it's but people have been working on
this list
it's mostly comprehensive
okay for some of this they the use is
pretty much pretty straightforward so
uh for cloud for example for cloud you
just specify
uh the url and for many of those as well
uh on the other hand for mail it's more
detailed there are many parameters
um
okay
okay um
i'm not sure we can really do this
meeting without brad
so because i need to ask a bunch of
questions about these services
because i'm not confident i mean what
you're showing me is basically something
that seems very much like um
um what am i trying to say that it seems
um
you know very similar to just persistent
value and so on
what what is the difference here between
the one difference is that well
this is a although it's implemented with
persistent value
and and in many cases we're using the
persistent you know
we're using the persistent value system
to store these things
it's that is not a user level api for
for
setting things right if i want to tell
someone to point
at a different cloud they're not going
to call so what's this
here what's this here this
is i'm trying to understand this is
setting this parameter
of this service is that correct yeah
i think this is a crazy way to do it i
what's wrong with an
l value an equal sign well so
this allows you to drill down the value
and set only one specific way for
example for mail above
you can just want to set a port
so that way you can drill down that
value and
set a specific yeah or password
well i don't understand how you do that
why can't you use an equal sign why
can't you use
so this is
so i don't understand you can so you can
you can use sql
sign if you want to set the value on the
other hand for example you want
to add a number of additional parameters
and uh setting would involve doing
many uh equal science but
you can use a single function
sensitivities to basically merge
the new the new uh set with the
with what's already there
okay this is really not useful i really
want to hear from brad
what the story is with these different
services okay
i want to see the list of services and i
want to go through and understand this
because this is not a design i can do
without knowing what these services need
to support because you're showing me a
few random services
and telling me right but it's not this
isn't a few random services this is a
pretty complete list
of all the services
how many i mean let's let's go and start
uh
there's a couple that i i didn't put in
because i thought they were
more speculative or or wouldn't be
configurable i think maybe the euro url
shortness here
um
where is url short now well but there's
nothing there what what i'm saying
there because
it because i don't there's just nothing
there because i didn't put anything
i don't know what the value there's no
support right now for changing the url
shortener
but it's going to be that's going to be
a very simple example it's going to be
set system service you know url
shortener
comma and then some url okay so this
thing for example
here okay this thing here there are all
kinds of timeout parameters
all kinds of maximum size parameters all
kinds of things here
and this needs to also merge with the
epc configuration
stuff right
did you understand what i'm saying in
the epc
i'm saying that the configuration for an
epc will contain some default
information about what is the timeout
what's the maximum size of a data bin
all that kind of thing right what's the
maximum rate of putting things into the
data bin
where does that that information is
presumably
in the configuration for the epc how
does it come out here
well but this api is is things that the
user can
set it's not the user wouldn't isn't set
able to
change the rate you know configuration
on the server so so hold on hold on
so this is in your session
okay okay i understand but
here all right so wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait there are multiple let's
say i'm dealing with three different
clouds
how do i deal with that here
well you can see that that shakes output
there has like wolfram arrow and a bunch
of settings and you know my company
arrow and another association right but
how do i know
that i don't have three data drops as
well
how do i know that there's an additional
layer here
of some qualification and there isn't
one here
well did you understand what i'm saying
yeah you can you can do the same thing
here
you're not but how would you specify
that
a couple things first the situation's
data drop it is
somewhat complicated by the fact that it
it's it's probably
linked to your cloud right so if if you
have an epc
you probably want data drop from some
well you may do it but okay so bradley
is here i'm glad
so you had a list of these potential
services right bradley can i see that
list
uh yeah it's a little outdated since
todd and constantine started working on
it but i'll pull it up
okay so take a second
okay stephen i just want to point out in
the data drop example
the default for data drop will be
something like
dollar data drop base so that would
that's something that can automatically
change
when we'll have some automatic values
associated with it to switch when you
switch
cloud data without drop base i know
right there isn't but i'm saying that
right now it's computed based on on uh
cloud base and and it's that's
something that would just you could set
it manually if you wanted but the
default
is not going to be a hardcore url it's
going to be automatic or something that
i just well i don't know what's the
relationship between dollar databand
base
and system service data data drop
do you understand what i'm asking yeah
system service data drop is a way
that you would set or get
the value of our data bin
well but i'm not sure that's what we
want to do because you could have
dollar everything right you can have uh
you know there's a dollar geo server
potentially as well
right yeah is there a dollar jio silver
or not
no there isn't no there's simply a geo
geoserver option
for certain functions right
right so here this is an example
yeah but it's not settable i mean it is
settable you can set it right here
but this is an example where system
service of geo server
the whole point of system service when
we invented it whatever two three years
ago
was to avoid just having a
giant you know boat load of dollar this
that and the other variables
right and to allow the
the bulk
setting so i mean let's just go through
the use cases again let's just go
through what we're trying to achieve
you've got a different genome server
that you want to use
maybe you want to use it only when
you're dealing with
the rat genome or something and you have
another one for the human genome
you see what i'm saying so
now what i'm a little bit confused by is
functions that
use a server they have specific names
like
jio server arrow whatever data bin ad
does not have a specific name
for the data drop server to to use
do you get what i'm saying so one of the
other issues we have is going
up a level to these functions where
something is choosable
right it could be that we say well
actually the function isn't going to
have an option
the way you would do it is some kind of
blocking of system service
and then just run the function in that
environment i'm not sure that's my
favorite
but otherwise we have to have in each of
these functions we have to have
the name of the server do you understand
what i'm saying yeah
yeah so what what what is your thinking
about that
yes so that's how we developed it so in
system services you can store
uh these values in some format
uh which geo server for example
can understand so geo server would know
that it would
it would need to reach a geo server
section
in the system services uh data
yep and from there it would get
information so
if you want to use one server for the
red and another for the human
so jewish shareware would need to know
which one to use for which but
the other things or all the other
information would be stored in
system services okay but but but
hold on a second because
i again you're not getting my point my
point is every function here
like this is geographics it has a
geoserver option
right so let's look at genome lookup
okay stephen i've got a notebook i'll
put the link in the
zoom chat okay thank you
okay thanks oh okay so
genome lookup does not appear to have
a server option do you understand what
i'm saying
yes so to make a local specification of
i want to use a different genome server
the question is how are we imagining
that's going to happen
so among the ways it could happen is you
know
block system service geo geo
genome server or something um
you know then genome lookup then end the
block that's one possibility i'm not
sure that's the best possibility but
that's one possibility
did you get what i'm saying the
alternative is that every one of these
has to have a genome server option at
which point i don't even know why we
have system services because
at that point we've already created a
symbol for this we might as well create
a dollar symbol as well
and so on well one thing about
about the dollar symbol idea is that
if we have system service then every not
every service needs to create its own
dollars
exactly exactly and we all
and we also provide persistent storage
for that value right dollar geo server
would be just something that
if if that if that existed it would
probably be something that was just hard
coded in some code somewhere and you
could set it within a session but
there'd be no
consistent storage of an altered value
for that without
the service you can you can have a
persistent storage
in different locations you know
different persistence levels
okay so what i want what i want to
understand is this
okay do we think the right way to do
this
okay so we have a model here for
uh what is the thing that that you
basically never set that allows you to
do things like
the crossovers for arithmetic what is
that called system
it's called um system option system
options
it's just an option i think
okay so here
okay so this is an utterly obscure giant
list
of things
okay caching options all kinds of things
here
right and
presumably in here i don't know whether
in here are the
are the servers set in here anywhere
no i think these are set in the c code
so they
have no access to that okay fine but so
answer this question i mean if what we
want is an escape valve to reset
servers what's wrong with system options
is such an escape valve
nothing yeah
the system options are not persistently
stored
no they're not that's correct they're
not i mean this is the look
what i'm trying to get out is this is a
deep escape valve
is system options but the thing we could
be doing with genome lookup
either it's sort of action at a distance
you set the system
you set something analogous to system
options you know system services you set
some particular thing there
to change it or it's something that's
very granular and local
right and you know possibly the way to
do that
is to have something where it says where
there's a generic
option you know system services
system service option or something arrow
whatever
and any one of those functions like
genome server
could have a fragment of the system
services
record i'm not sure this is a good idea
but i'm just saying
that what you could do is have something
where
rather than genome lookup having to have
its own personalized symbol
to deal with changing system services to
have something generic like that
yeah system server might be
yeah that might be a reason no but
that's what that's what it would do it
would just go to system services
and look up its own thing so there's no
need for option at all
it's well that's not right that's not
right
that's not right think about the code
okay think about the code you're writing
right let's say i'm trying to change it
i want this to be the blue server
okay right and and now the the code i
write otherwise
is set system service
you know genome server
and then i guess i say blue slash blue
okay
you can use right something like that
right
yeah okay now how do i do this locally
now i see genome lookup
of you know whatever it is some some
sequence in the rat
um and and then i have to revert it how
do i do that
whereas this is a localized use of that
system server
okay so but here you need to explain
what blue means
and in genome lookup you just say system
service option blue
and the the whole bunch of settings will
be stored in system sharing
and then uh
you do search youtube service only once
in your store for genome series blue all
those
okay so so then this is a bit like a
theme it's a bit like a style or a theme
so i mean this is something like you
know system service setting or something
i don't know
what it's exactly called this is a
reasonable thing to do
this is the thing where that that's a
good compromise because what you could
do here
is if you want to give a whole structure
locally you give the association here
otherwise you simply refer to it by a
theme name
effectively yeah okay
i like this idea this is a sensible idea
because then we can have a generic
setting here and it knows so so one
thing that's a little tricky
is that genome lookup has to know
oh i look for the themes associated with
uh genome server but its name isn't
genome server you see what i'm saying
right so in other words there may be
many functions like geo
i don't know geo region value plot
okay and it needs to know that
the thing it's looking for is the geo
server so we can document that that's
okay
right exactly and each each group that
wants to hook into it will have to write
those hookups so whoever's writing the
geo functions
would be the one that says you know
determines how the option
works for them what information it
retrieves right
but so okay and let's go ahead i was
just gonna say that
right every group that uses this system
services even in a current design
without this option
has to do that has to will write some
code in their
package that interacts with the system
services framework and
this is just another way in which they
would be specifying how they interact
with the framework
okay question i mean um
themes plot themes how do you set a new
plot theme how do you set up a new plot
theme
you could set it the same way so it's
basically
on the but that's not how it's being
done right now
right so how is it being done right now
is my question
let's try i don't know okay we need to
find out
it might be set in the style sheet like
for example how do i set
from code you know another place where
we're storing stuff is in style sheets
and arguably okay this meeting was not
set up correctly okay
this meeting should have had in it also
you know like
connor who's dealing with the paclet you
know settings for paclets and so on
what is the what is the bright line
between a system service
and something like like
i assume the menu setup is not a system
service
no what is a system cell yeah the way i
had
oh sorry go on go ahead i was gonna say
the way i had envisioned it
is the system servers um
our and services uh are
externally hosted servers that power
built-in functionality
yeah okay so you rely on something
outside of your local system
to actually evaluate this function
it's in mail data bin resource system
geo stuff there's all a server that
powers it and that's that's been my
that's reasonable how does this relate
to service deploy
i'm not familiar enough with that
so the concept of service deploy and and
i think todd maybe you can speak to this
i think it's being used in orphan
application server
it's the thing to set an external
service
do you see what i'm saying so for
example service deploy will be the
correct way to set up a mail receiver
function
that is i'm setting an external service
to have this mail address that will be
sent back in this way
right so so what is the first i mean
when i'm when i'm using service deploy
with welcome application server
what i don't actually know off the top
of my head what that looks like
no i don't either i think i think it's
like
um a service execute
right which has the service name first
right so there's a service name so
so system service the system service
framework then is the thing that can
associate
a service name with the set with
the url for that service and maybe other
settings like your
username and password and things so that
your code can be
can just say you know service deploy to
was or whatever
and but you use the system services
framework to yeah that's sensible just
to define what was means
the line between those for me
and it's not a very strong line is the
difference between
built-in language functionality and
extended functionality
so you say service execute i think of
the um
service connect yeah in in my mind
there's kind of one framework for
service connections because those
those are like extensions and system
services
is for the things that are that are
built into the language but that's not a
very bright one
it's not all that bright line although
it is a somewhat bright line because
that's
again another set of people who should
have been involved here are the people
dealing with integrated services right
because
things like text translation that's
about to go from being an external
service to not being an external service
okay and uh like for example
you know the acceptance of license terms
for an external service how is that
related to all of this
that's a thing that we need to so so
right when you first use
text translation for example our
agreement with the external service
providers is that we have to pop
up some kind of thing that says i agree
with these terms
okay it will be very good to tokenize
that effectively
and basically to be able to store in the
system services set
up um something which indicates i have
accepted this
uh no problem with that so uh
another paradigm here is a registry
on windows so registry is a system
is operating system provided uh database
of some sort
and all the programs that run on windows
uh sooner or later they read some value
values from the register exactly so
that's what
that's basically what system services is
it's just it's some kind of uh
configuration database
uh it's right the thing that's tricky
about it for example is
how uh you know how global should that
database be should it follow you
like for example if i use it that way
and i like that way of using it because
i think that is an extensible
you know it's a concept that's usefully
extensible the
issue is know
like i could have assist okay let's say
that i've
set my screen on one computer
to be uh i have some special color
setting because
my monitor is on the fritz and i want it
to be i don't know what some different
color
yeah okay so so this way uh also the
genome look up uh with this with the
same blue
so how do you know whether blue is
defined on your local computer or
somewhere on the server
outside same idea
and uh probably we could just uh
do a look up one of the other so we look
up locally and if it's not set down
right which is what we do for persistent
value if i'm not mistaken
that's exactly what persistence path
does right
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah that stage
but steven i just want to say that
although what constantine has built
is actually at its core it's this
it's just a system for storing data
data in the form of associations and
lead values
and uh in a persistent storage location
but but it's not but the api system
service
that users use it's not designed to be
an arbitrary
option setting holder right for anything
why not it's designed for well because i
think
because i think then that it becomes a
little too general
for example if you if you do system
services just open bracket close record
you see a list of all the system
services
now would that would that include a
hundred things of every kind of
yeah you know actually that's what
you're doing when you release system
options
yeah it's a big mess right but system
options is not a user-friendly thing
system options like you just said it's a
big mess we're trying to create
something that
users will use well i understand but i'm
not too worried about
i mean
same if you look in the registry on
windows it's also a big mess
but each program knows but the
registry is not in any way a user level
no
no all right i'm not sure that this is
imagine
most users are going to use this
directly i would think a lot of the
different services would have their way
of registering nothing more like a site
and i also want how this relates to
paclets like
can a paclet set your local system
service or not
i i don't see that a packet would
automatically
set something like that for you right i
i don't even
listen to the pack that has water
language code and can run
when you know you load the packer they
can send anything you like
by calling set system service but pack
let's just buy their
to some metadata way i don't think they
would ever want them to be setting these
things
it doesn't it doesn't really make sense
i'm not even sure you want them
in general to be setting them i mean i i
i you know i guess the pack
could set anything you want i mean it
could set two plus two equals 18 or
something
in principle yeah exactly yeah right but
but going back to the the system service
api
we already have persistent value
there's already a means if if i as a
if if the implementer of some framework
wants to store
persistent values for various uses we've
already got that
we're building something that has um
special uses and limitations
designed for a certain purpose on top of
the persistent value so
users are not users and developers who
are writing packages that will make use
of this framework
are not having to deal directly with
the uh persistent values all right look
part of the point here
is knowing what we have to package up
for an epc
yeah right and
so
what is all of this so this is what the
heck is this
this callback thing this is purely
implementation detail i don't think it's
we should be looking at this at this
point this is just an implementation
detail of
not really not part of the part of the
i think it should be part of the api but
wait wait wait wait wait so the first
question is
gosh what the heck is this
it's an it's a possible syntax for
drilling down it could be
using the slash notation it's just a
possible idea for
filling down as opposed to like a list
of values it is quite convenient
it actually follows the persistent
object idea but uh it's quite does it
in what way it does it supports the same
way it supports
this uh um okay because it's basically
thinking of it like a file system
right you it's kind of you drill down
the
the value that you store it
so it assumes that you have a nice
hierarchy
and you go just go down yeah but too
much faster i find myself using it all
the time rather than the
list notation it's more convenient to
organize because
you have natural heart yeah
um
okay i am i am running out of time here
unfortunately this meeting
was let's decide how this meeting goes
forward i mean
there is you know we need to zoom out we
need okay who is dealing with epc
configuration
um i know whoever is skillful okay
whoever is dealing with it whoever is
making the epc configuration
needs to be in the next version of this
meeting i think it would be useful
um
because this has got to relate to
when you configure an epc it is
precisely setting
the default installation-wide settings
of system services
isn't it yes
yes exactly and this is this function
set
system service is exactly what an epc
administrator
would call right but let me remind you
that an epc configuration
is done through notebooks so there's an
existing notebook
you know gui effectively for setting a
bunch of these
things which should be merged with this
yeah which is probably
not a good idea for notebook mail
send mail was configured only through
gui and it was not convenient because
you cannot send email
from the rock or no you can't configure
it
right well so so okay so we got let's
inventory for this thing we've got
another place
is the preferences dialogue that's
another so i want to know
where the place is you know this is an
integrative
thing right it's integrating many
different pieces of functionality
so another one it's integrating is the
preferences dialogue right
okay so i need to see that wow what on
earth is that uh
that needs to be reported as bugs this
is the relationship all sorts
wait wait wait wait wait i want to make
sure do i have to report this
is somebody here able to report this
okay yeah thank you
okay so what you're going to say and i'm
going to leave then uh there's also
um the old style uh
uh front end um options the dialogue
okay all right so listen you've got to
get together the correct meeting here
next time uh you know if you have to you
can confirm the attendee list with me
before
we show up but this wasn't the right set
of people
right well steven it was this meeting
was
right well you're not ready you're not
ready
you've got to understand how this
relates to you know
the preferences dialogue how it relates
to epc startup it's no good to just say
this is going to be the design of this
particular little you know
proboscis at the end of the you know
so so the idea was to have
some implementation and see how all this
large number of pieces uh that's fine
but let's
zoom out a bit you know we've waited
long enough for this let's zoom out a
bit
and understand how it relates to these
other things
okay okay and let's get another meeting
about this
and uh i'll see that okay i'm going to
disappear
okay bye-bye